sir I need your help
I knew this moment would come and I will
be the bigger man I'd be happy to help
great we need a doctor here immediately
we have to get your ex-boyfriend I will
not help you things did not end well
between Frederick and me oh why not fish
service Gina no I can't believe I'm
saying this but we simply don't have
time to hear about the captain sordid
romantic past what have you become a
hero in a time of Crisis you stay here
and take care of Sharon oh
pregnant when I get in there in there
then you'll deal with it sir we're going
to get Frederick right now I'm sure he's
over whatever little fight you guys had
Frederick Happy Thanksgiving
Please don't slam the door again we have
a bit of a medical situation I wish I
could help but unfortunately I have a
bit of a wooden duck situation excuse me
what now still on about the duck
Frederick years ago when we moved in
together an antique duck decoy of his
was misplaced it wasn't misplaced you
threw it in the trash and with it our
relationship oh please we had other
problems or have you forgotten about
Dave Dave and I were co-workers and
nothing more nothing more right problem
solved everybody's friends let's go help
Sharon I will be happy to assist you if
you will just admit Raymond that you
threw my decoy in the garbage that will
never happen because it's not true thank
you for nothing good day
hi would you mind just standing there
with your glorious beard for one moment
I'll be right back
just tell him what he wants to hear but
it's a lie I don't give a crap sir
Sharon needs a doctor so get over
yourself I'm telling you throw away his
stupid duck they give him 20 bucks to
buy a new one it costs 740 what
same price for a duck that's way too
much
now I'm angry about the wrong thing look
just fix this for Sharon
if Friedrich the duck was ugly and gross
and I threw it in the garbage wow well I
know what I'm thankful for this
Thanksgiving the truth
Terry's still not answering his phone
why am I the only one who cares about
this baby
hey what took so long is she okay uh
yeah I was just telling her the entire
duck story now that it finally has a
satisfying ending now everything's fine
but I am a little concerned about
Sharon's blood pressure and this is a
terrible environment I would call it
terrible we're surrounded by criminals
there's no bed and you can hear the
faint sound of someone screaming through
all the vents that's Hitchcock his arm's
stuck in a Pneumatic too it's hilarious
in my professional opinion Sharon should
go to the hospital Peralta
can I confess something to you
I didn't throw Frederick's duck in the
garbage yes I know sir I didn't throw
the duck in the garbage I threw it off a
bridge
why would you do that well Frederick and
I were having problems he knew I
disliked the duck because of its weak
peek but he insisted on displaying it
anyway I acted out in a petty manner
just as I did today
I'm sorry that I wasn't more helpful
it's fine I understand you might find
this hard to believe but I can be a
little childish sometimes myself yes
you have gum in your hair right now
noted these spindles are gorgeous and
there's almost a feeling of musculature
for this transition the oak just sort of
told me the shape before I even got to
the spoke shave this under bevel is a
great trick it really makes it feel
lighter while leaving you plenty of beef
to carve it's really just a modified
Danish line still you made it your own
this is as good a chair as I've seen I
have nothing left to teach you
hurray
thank you
look at this it's taking a class open to
new things see aren't you glad that I
picked the art of bread they said there
was a special guest teacher I wonder who
it is I know who it is Jackson Boudreau
no way from extreme bread we watch that
show all the time I make his bread
all the time there's so much more than
bread he's worldly
all I know is the episode where he
rolled naked and breadcrumbs sent me to
heaven
be cool
I am Jackson Boudreau and this
is the art of bread
bread making love making what's the
difference
nothing
we need both
and we need both
manly
so let's make love Everyone by which I
mean bread and then we'll make love
again by which I mean more bread now
who's horny
for bread
[Music]
not bad huh
are you making an ashtray
no
no that Jackson
I love your ashtray thank you very much
you've been rough with her I like it
I sense you are a woman of
contradictions no I'm not what wait oh I
guess I am
delightful I would like to spend time
with you me I love that as a question
just one thing though I hate the term
celebrity but I'm a very big one things
end up in the Tabloid I hate gossip more
than anyone
I heard it ruined Ben Affleck's marriage
you were damaged in the most beautiful
way aren't you
I am
we will be in touch now you go bake that
bad girl
it's not bad
it's just misunderstood
[Applause]
a noble failure
mission to bake
that's quite a loaf you've got there
thank you my
my challah makes the boys holla
I love it when my students make jokes
you've done this before haven't you well
I I dabble
you Dabble you are so you aren't you you
know you saw so but it is so nice to
hear someone else say it
yeah I gotta say a big fan you know it
was it was so cool when that one Baker
refused to bake the the cake for the gay
wedding the way she
don't let words get in the way of what
we want to say to each other
[Laughter]
that's right
oh yeah
I would like to spend time with you
I feel the same you won't tell anyone
okay I don't know anyone